hello my name is dan salvato
i'm the creator of the psychological
horror game doki doki literature club
and now after a lot of really passionate
work from a whole bunch of people
i'm delighted to share doki doki
literature club plus with you for the
first time
i'm sure some of you already can't wait
to revisit your friends in the club
but if you're new to doki doki
literature club we're excited for you to
meet the club members for the first time
on pc
nintendo switch playstation or xbox this
summer
ddlc plus gives the original pc game
high definition visuals and brings it to
a number of new platforms
it's also packed with all kinds of new
features and content for both existing
fans and new players to experience and
enjoy
there's a lot of cool stuff for me to go
over but there are also some things that
you'll have to discover for yourself
when you play the game
ddlc is a game that explores the unique
kind of relationship that people can
have with fictional characters
and the relationship they have with
video games in general i wanted to make
a game that causes people to think more
deeply about how they mentally and
emotionally process
their experience with fiction and using
psychological horror to deeply disturb
them is a really effective way of
achieving that
i always felt like the members of the
literature club deserved more of a space
to get to know each other and kind of
explore their interpersonal
relationships
so for ddlc plus i wrote a new storyline
that i call the side stories
the side stories are unrelated to the
events of the original game
and they instead focus on how all the
club members went from first meeting
each other to becoming close friends
i really wanted to create an environment
where these characters
have to learn to overcome their
communication barriers
and respect each other's needs and
reflect on themselves
and i think that will be really
meaningful to those of you who relate to
the characters
or maybe even find yourselves in similar
situations i think this is a great time
for some wholesome storytelling that can
help keep us inspired to continue
improving ourselves and our
relationships with others
the side stories also have a brand new
soundtrack to go along with them
music has always been an important part
of ddlc and
really important to me personally as a
part of playing video games
i love how music tracks sort of absorb
all the emotions you feel during the
game
and how it all comes rushing back
whenever you hear the songs again
so for the side stories i brought in a
new composer nikki kylar
who shares the same passion and
understanding of the special impact of
video game music
nikki and i worked really closely
together on songs that have some
familiar catchy melodies along with a
bunch of brand new ones
to make it even better ddlc plus has a
built-in music player
the music player has 26 music tracks in
total i really hope you enjoy
discovering the new music as you play
the side stories which will also unlock
them in the music player
speaking of unlockables another fun new
feature is the picture gallery
where you can unlock pictures as you
play the game there are more than 100
unlockable pictures like game artwork
wallpapers and never before seen concept
sketches of certain memorable scenes
from the game
i think it's a fun way to encourage
people to try new things in dlc
and see if they can discover all the
content it's not easy to reach 100
content completion
but i bet if you and your friends share
each of your own discoveries you'd be
able to do it together
that's about it for the stuff i'm ready
to talk about today
for everything else you'll just have to
discover it yourself i know that there's
always a concern with re-releases or
special editions
having a whole bunch of changes to them
or the original content being tampered
with in some way
so we thoughtfully included all the new
content
in a way that ensures the main game doki
doki literature club
is as authentic and true to the original
as possible
overall i really wanted to make ddlc
plus
not only really special for existing
fans but also a
fantastic and accessible way for new
players to get in
on the psychological horror experience
[Applause]
[Music]
you